bonjour j'allais dire bonsoir bonjour
nicolas vidal
bonjour merci d'être avec nous ce matin
sur rtl france les sondages nous disent
qu'il y aura un duel entre marine le pen
et emmanuel macron quels sont les enjeux
à treize mois de ces élections nicolas
et bien voilà la course à l'échalote
présidentielle est lancée shermag a dit
on en avait déjà parlé il ya un mois
mais les plaques tectoniques en fait
elles bougent vigoureusement du fait
d'un calendrier politique qui s'accélère
aussi bien pour les partis pour les
grands médias que pour les célèbre
éditorialiste et il faut le dire ça va
nous occuper de plus en plus car
l'échéance 2022 risque d'être pétillante
je vous l'annonçais alors on nous dit
que le choix de ces serait fait
finalement ses pieds braves gens on nous
annonce avec tambours trompettes et
flonflons audio macron le pen alors même
qu'un sondage récent on la vit pendant
avait parlé 70 % des français seraient
opposés à cette doublette magique mais
triste finalement il y aurait donc le
vote anticipé mais les résultats
également qui serait anticipée alors
cette présidentielle s annonce très
glissante pour moi
les chroniqueurs politiques de
l'impossible mais aussi pour l'avenir de
la france
alors on va tenter ce matin de
comprendre les enjeux les lignes de
fracture et les chausse-trappes parce
que de grosses surprises ne serait pas
impossible d'ici là à magali et nicolas
qu'est ce que vous pensez des partis
historiques les républicains le parti
socialiste est ce qu'il pourrait être
hors jeu dès le premier tour
à l'heure actuelle il faut concéder que
la situation ne laisse que peu de place
au doute
les deux partis historiques sont
totalement disqualifié de la course
présidentielle et pourquoi
mais concernant le ps il est totalement
moribond le ps d'ailleurs lorsque vous
allez sur leur site à vous pouvez vous
rafraîchir la mémoire en quittant
turquie sommes nous mais vous vous y
trouverez difficilement la composition
du bureau national de plus le parti en
très grande difficulté financière
car le parti socialiste est un vieux
parti politique mais c'est aussi un plan
social à lui tout seul on a appris
récemment le départ de 11 salariés
annoncée par olivier faur en fait les
cte oralement le ps peser moins de 7% à
la dernière présidentielle et son plus
gros problème va être de remplir deux
pages de programmes d'ailleurs il n'est
pas à exclure une alliance avec les
écologistes peut-être pour se partager
le travail c'est à dire une passe chacun
alors oui ça va pas fort au ps pour les
républicains c'est le tombeau des
danaïdes et conviction perdu c'est
l'assurance d'être une nouvelle fois
humilier à cossette minutie
ra dickey la fibre gaulliste de chacune
de leurs idées politiques corroborer
bien entendu à cette obsession à courir
derrière emmanuel macron en permanence
sans comptez vous le savez que les
républicains se servent toujours un
candidat naturel dans l'armoire des
souvenirs de la défunte ump et on le
sait maintenant
nicolas sarkozy n'a que peu de chance de
remonter sur le ring donc aujourd'hui il
ya comme très forte odeur de raclée qui
plane au 238 2 rue de vaugirard à paris
le siège des républicains on verra cela
mais qu'est-ce qui pourraient donc
empêcher ce fameux duel emmanuel macron
et marine le pen que les français ne
veulent pas d'ailleurs oui mais le tueur
vous l'avez dit d'un malien est bien ce
duel emmanuel macron mme le pen pourrait
30 du plan dans l'aide dans les
prochains mois pourquoi alors qu on va
se rappeler de la déclaration emmanuel
macron et aux médias brut en décembre
dernier j'y reviens tout le temps il
disait emmanuel macron peut-être que je
devrais faire des choses qui
m'empêcheront d'être candidat donc il
laissait entrevoir que la violence des
réformes à venir pourrait l'empêcher de
se représenter en 2022 mais peut-être
aussi qu'avaient ils avaient compris
manuel mâcon collet gilet jaune n'était
que le hors d'oeuvre de la contestation
populaire
de plus vous le savez je le deviens en
permanence il doit tenir la feuille de
route de la troïka fmi commission
européenne bce
or ils risquent d'être lâchés en rase
campagne bruxelloise par ses créanciers
européens d'ailleurs pas très porté sur
les questions de démocratie et la crise
sanitaire elle elle pourrait être fatal
à ses réformes central de ce quinquennat
du côté de marine le pen c'est
extrêmement intéressant parce qu'elle
risque le sort funeste que koné à droite
avec un rejet populaire et d'une partie
de sa base
alors pourquoi parce que marine le pen
elle est en train de témoigner une
allégeance remarquable à bruxelles est
en réalité au système pour être quoi
pour être présidentiable
j'en donne bardella 1 sont seconds
déclaré d'ailleurs le 7 mars dernier sur
les jeunes confrères de france info
qu'il n'était pas question pour le rn de
sortir de l'euro alors l'url il commet
donc à mes erreurs que les vieux partis
historiques mais pas pour les mêmes
raisons
car marine le pen en fait elle est
persuadée que proposait la sortie
l'union européenne dont la france
précipiterait sa défaite alors que c'est
absolument le contraire parce que la
président du rn finalement n'arrivent
toujours pas à faire la jonction
politique entre identité et souveraineté
et puis parlons aussi de la menace
10 hier qui pèsent sur est à savoir l'
enquête sur les assistants du rn
parlement européen procès qui ne devrait
pas intervenir bien entendu un relent
présidentielle mais restons tout de même
prudent et pour terminer
alors si oui les variants politique
pourrait supplanter le duo souches sur
savoir mais le manuel macron marine le
pen c'est ainsi qu'eric zemmour à vous
le savez nicolas dupont aignan florian
philippot ou encore philippe de villiers
pourrait avoir une belle carte à jouer
pour des confiné et lecteurs épris de
souveraineté si le parquet national
financiers bien entendu se gardent
d'appliquer les gestes barrière d'ici
l'élection de mai 2022
merci beaucoup m nicolas vidal un édito
à retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux et
on se retrouve bien évidemment jeudi
prochain dans la matinale en